the dark knight is a beacon of hope
literally in one of the most goosebump
inducing scenes from the batman and fans
can't stop talking about it warning
spoilers for the batman ahead the batman
is darker than any previous iteration of
the mask vigilante's story with variety
describing it as a grounded frequently
brutal film noir
total film magazine quoted director matt
reeves as calling his movie the scariest
batman movie yet and critics and
audiences seem to agree
one element adding to the movie's dark
tone is the way batman is treated by
citizens of gotham
at best they're wary of him two years
into his career as a crime fighter he's
not exactly seen as a superhero not even
the christopher nolan movies made the
batman seem like such a threat to
regular people this is made clear at the
start of the film when on halloween
night a gang of thugs beat up on a man
riding public transportation when batman
swoops into a subway station to meet out
his personal brand of justice he lays
the bad guys out with ruthless
efficiency but then instead of being
grateful the victim cowers and asks
batman not to hurt him the scene
establishes batman as a frightening
force for everyone not just the bad guys
that's the way it stays for most of the
movie with comparisons being drawn
between the supposedly heroic batman and
the supposedly villainous riddler but
that all starts to change at the end of
the film with a scene that's giving fans
goosebumps and for good reason
fear is a tool
this goosebumps-inducing scene takes
place at the very end of the film batman
has failed in his efforts to contain the
riddler's damage not realizing until too
late that the criminal has placed
explosives at seven of gotham's sea
walls when they go off water floods the
city including gotham square garden
where the mayor elect bella real is
giving a victory speech to a crowd full
of gotham's most important people
batman soars in to save everyone but
before he does that he has to deal with
the internet army that the riddler has
put together who are on hand to make
sure the villain's plan goes smoothly in
the aftermath a number of people are
trapped by the collapsed building so
batman goes to rescue them at first they
are hesitant to accept batman's help not
knowing his motives the first to take
batman's offered hand is the young son
of former mayor don mitchell jr orphan
bruce wayne sees a bit of himself in the
boy whose father was killed at the start
of the film a young woman tentatively
follows eventually everyone lets him
lead them out of there through the
flooding waters batman ignites a red
flare and holds it up to light the way
becoming a literal beacon of hope
i'm vengeance the scene is part of the
character's own journey in the film
batman starts out moodily telling his
enemies that he's the personification of
vengeance later one of the riddler's
cronies says the same about himself when
batman asks him why he's helping to
cause such terror in the city at that
point batman realizes how much in common
he has with the bad guys and it prompts
him to reflect on his mission and what
he wants to stand for at the end of the
movie bruce realizes that he can't just
stand for vengeance he has to be a
symbol of hope this scene coupled with
bruce's emotional growth allows the film
to end on a somber yet optimistic note
posters on reddit discuss the scene in
detail with one user on reddit praising
the hard-hitting theme they wrote this
was a pivotal concept that batman had to
confront in order to find a sense of
justice built on something more stable
than anger and vengeance batman needs to
be fear but he also must be hope another
user on reddit gave their thumbs up as
well writing the whole character arc of
the batman from the vengeance to hope
was showcased masterfully one user on
reddit thought the scene was meaningful
and visually beautiful writing that
scene when he's helping the people in
the flooded area and leading them to a
safe place is just beautiful visually
and story wise perfect depiction of
batman being the beacon of hope it makes
sense that batman would be facing this
character development at this early
stage of his career as a caped crime
fighter naturally a city facing such
rampant crime would be suspicious of a
masked interloper diving in to take
matters into his own hands
after dealing with the threat of the
riddler however the people of gotham and
batman himself have a better idea of
what he's actually trying to accomplish
justice
the answer's justice
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]